サッサと判断して行動する人々がアサンカーリカ
無行 心の中ではどうしようか
どうしようか あだこうだとか
時間かからないんですね
行動には時間がかからない
瞬時に判断して行動する
いわゆる鈍いか鋭いかというぐらいの性格的な差なんですね
それは 大体性格的な鈍い人はほとんど鈍い
行動は鈍い 理解は鈍い
遅くちょっと遅くなる
鋭い人はもう勉強することにしても
すぐ聞いてすぐわかったと
行動にしてもすぐ行動してしまうと
行動は早い それはみんなこの無行ということで
結構聞いて頭の中で考えて徐々に理解する人はやっぱり有行で
そういう人は行動するときでもいくらか考えてゆっくりと行動に至るということですから
その心の鋭さ 鋭い心はアサンカーリカ
それほど鋭くない心はササンカーリカというふうに分けられる
その分け方は大体カルマの結果としてはそれほど危険がない
行為の結果には でも個人として個人の性格としては差があるんです
もうこの前の説明いたしましたから
なんで有行無行っていうのはそんなややこしい
どうでもいい区別を考えてるんですかと
これアビダンマの心理学っていうのは
やっぱり悟る人の心の変換ですか
変えることのことをきちんとした科学的に説明したがっているんですね
いわゆる仏教の悟りというのはお釈迦な
得体知れない わけのわからないものではなくて
きちんとした心の転換だから
きちんとしたものだから
そちらにはちゃんときちんとした科学的な解釈
説明はあるんですね ですからこの悟る場合は
このかなりゆっくりゆっくりと成長していって
まあやがて悟る人もいて
まあもう修行したらもうもうなんとかもうあっちこっちあっち向いてこっち向くと
もうもう悟って終わったという人もいるし
そういうこの心変える早さなんです
例えば怒りを何とかしなさいと
僕もいろんな方々にいろんなことを言いますけど
よくわかります よくわかりますと言いながらまた元に戻る
また悩んできて また説明したらよくわかりましたと
で また行ってまた元に戻ると
これもう何年も経ったところで
もうやっとわかりましたと
心が変わりましたと言うんだから結構時間かかると
そういうの性格の差なんですね
聞いてすぐもう心変わったよとという人も結構いるし
それは性格の差で なかなか自分の癖から逃げられないというのは
もう有行の人々で もう瞬時にもう悪いとわかったらもうすぐそれで終わりと
それはその瞬間的にもうすぐ変える人は無行の心を持ってる人
それは修行に対しては大変大事なポイントなんですね
瞑想する 瞑想指導する場合は
瞑想する人にとっても
いわゆるなかなか悟らなくたっても気長くしてゆっくりと頑張ればいいんです
結構難しい仕事だから
こういう辺でも入りますけど
その辺ではあんまり意味がないんです
まあそれで心は 善行為の心は8種類が現れますね
この分析で 明るい心 楽しい心
智慧があってアサンカーリカの心と
明るい心で智慧があってササンカーリカ心と
明るい心で智慧がない
なく ないアサンカーリカ心と
明るい心で智慧がないササンカーリカ心と
それから明るさがない普通の冷静な気持ち
感情で智慧がある心のアサンカーリカの心とササンカーリカの心と
智慧が冷静な感情の心で智慧がない
で アサンカーリカとササンカーリカと
そういうふうに8種類が出ているんです
人間する全てのこの善行為はこの心でやってるんです
ですから 例えば教える
勉強する 仕事をする 料理作る
掃除 洗濯をする そういうのはこの善の心でするならば
明るいか あるいはごく普通できつくない
ごく普通か どっちかなんですね
それで何やったとしても何か智慧
例えば掃除機をかける時でも
ちゃんとした智慧があって
目覚めた状態でやっちゃうと
その中でもいろんなこの智慧が生まれてくるんですね
落ち着きがなく もうやらなくちゃいけないんだからといって慌てて掃除かける人は
20年掃除かけたっても
掃除について何の智慧も生まれてこないんですね
ですから テレビなんか見てると
大体お正月が近づいてくると
どのように上手に掃除をかけますかというのを教えてくれるおばあさんたちが出てくるでしょうね
[笑い]それはどういうことかというと
その方々は自分の仕事はやっぱりそれなりに真剣に楽しくやってるんですね
畳炭の場合はこういう風にかけます
こういう風にかけた方があまり力は使わないんだと
時間はもうもっと短い時間でできるんだと
炭はこういう風に剃るんだと
埃はこういう風に取るんだとかね
そういう何のこともないところにでもいろいろ知恵が出てくる
その中では因果法則あるんだから
そういうわかってくるんですね
例えばもう一応掃除機を出しちゃったんだから
この部屋のもう掃除機をかけましょうと
じゃあそれからもう上の壁のホコリを取りますと思っちゃったら
もう無駄な努力でしょうに
そこで怠けが働いていて
もう掃除機を外に出しちゃった
ですから もういっぺんに全部やりましょうと
それからまた壁やら上の天井の掃除はしてないんだから
それから電球やらそういうそういう照明具やら
それを外したりしたり
また後で丁寧にやりますと丁寧にやるかもしれませんだけど
自分にはもう気がつかないところで
またせっかく掃除したところで汚れてしまうんですね
ですから この怠けが働いちゃうと
そこで知恵が生まれてこない
でも因果法則を知っている人は
やっぱり掃除は上から下へと
埃はもうどうしても軽いもんだから上に飛びますよと
ですから上から下やりますと
そういう風になっちゃうんですね
それからまあ奥から外へとかね
外のところから奥まで掃除機じゃなくて
奥から外へ 掃除機のお尻からまた吸出するほこり
また出てきちゃうでしょ
あの掃除機ってのは本当にインチキなところなんです
ですから やっぱり部屋の奥から始めた方がいいんです
だから そういう風に このちょっとしたつまらないことでも
こういう心で 善なるこういう心でやると
行為自体も善行為になって徳が積んじゃうし
知恵も生まれてくるし
それうえ仕事は楽しいし
人生はつまらない 全然言わない
人生はつまらないんだ
ああだこうだとか なんとかしなくちゃとか
パチンコでもやらなくちゃ
早く掃除終わってパチンコに行かなくちゃとかね
その人にとっては 知恵がある人にとっては
掃除することで刺激があって楽しい
で 気持ちがいい 気持ちがいいと
これは掃除にあまり集中した
ちょっと余計に集中しましたけど
掃除じゃなくて どんなことでも我々には仕事もして
その上それは善行為にもするということはできるんですね
例えば知恵が掃除機をかけると知恵が使う
どうやら知恵が使う 掃除機かける時も
我々にはこの物事の生滅変化が見えるはずなんですね
ものは変化する 無常であると
で それはよく見えるはずなんですね
照明具と呼んで 具と呼んでいいんですか
それを外しちゃうと やっぱりかなり汚れていて
それで拭く 拭いたっても
やっぱり買った時の色はもう変わってるんですね
もう黄色くなりかけているんです
目に見えないんだけど
よく見ると見えるんです
それは埃の色を吸いちゃって
例えばほとんどプラスチックですから
もう二度とあの色はもう変わりません
それで蛍光の光であろうとも
当たるとどんどんあのものの中身が変わっていっちゃうんです
蛍光灯ですから 今全部あるのは蛍光灯にカバーしているだけですよ
綺麗な それで綺麗なこのしているカバーにずっと蛍光灯の光が当たっている
だから僕らは光さえ物質だよと言ってるんだから
物質はその中に入っちゃうと
その中の物質構成が変わっていっちゃう
で 空気に触れてどんどん変化していくんだと
で いろんな変化 いろんな無常を見えてくるんです
あるいは掃除機したっても
掃除機した終わった瞬間から汚れていくんですね
掃除機をかけたあの瞬間だけ
あ 綺麗やと すぐまた空気がそこに入っちゃいますから
そこに空気のるほこりはもうまた溜まり始めているんですね
ですから ただ掃除をするだけであって
まあずっと物事は変化していく
汚れがずっと入れっぱなし
そこで流れいつでも埃が流れていく
ここで一応まとめて捨てるんだけど
また流れてくる またまとめしちゃうんだけど
また そこに物事の生と滅が
あるいは滅と生が綺麗にあるんです
自分の体を見ても 掃除機が始まる前には体力があったんだけど
終わる時は腰の方がちょっと微かに痛いとかね
ちょっと疲れたとかね
体も変化していく 掃除機始めた時分と終わった時の自分
気持ちとしても変わっているとか
そういうものは観察すると
それはヴィパッサナー瞑想になってしまうんです
そうすると高い知恵になっちゃうんです
抜群の知恵生まれますよ
恐ろしいほどのもの ちょっと人間探検でもしてみてください
何も勉強やら知識やら本を読むとかね
そんなこと何もなく 単館な簡単単純な自分やっているつまらないことだけ
気持ちよく明るくやっている人々
たまにみんなじゃないんだけど
喋ってみてください いかに優れている行動な知恵を持っているか
そういう人々もいますよ
ですからこの私たちにはね
知恵が生まれるためには
特別に何かどこかの有名なもう人気ある道場に行かなくちゃとかね
まあそうだこうだとか
そんな別にそうすると仏教の普遍性は消えちゃうんでしょう
決まってる国で決まってる場所で決まってる道場でやらなくちゃいけないんだと
イスラム教みたいにメッカに行って祈りしなきゃ
もう神には聞こえないんだから
みんなメッカを見てやらなくちゃいけないんですね
だからまあ 神のアンテナはメッカにある石なんです
あるいはイスラム教でなければ入れない
すごいもう厳しいところで
ですからこの仏教にしても
そういうどこかの聖地とかね
そういうところに行かなくちゃいけないとかって言っちゃうと
仏教の普遍性は消えちゃうんですね
聖者がいるところに行かなくちゃいけない
聖地へ行かなくちゃいけないとか
お釈迦様はそういうことも言ってないし
どこでも自分の台所の中でもね
知恵ある人には悟ることはできるんです
だからそこら辺ちょっとだけ自分の考え方を変えるだけなんです
まあそういうのは仏教の話なんですけど
アビダンマではね そんなこと言わなくてもいいんだけど
余計なことばっかり知ってる
じゃああの怒りがない心
欲がない心 その欲の代わりに何が不貪という心なの？不貪というのはものが自分で取ろうではなくて
自分から物事を施してあげようというふうな気持ちなんですね
あれ 見返りは求めない心なんですね
掃除機をかけてあげると
みんな綺麗なところで生活をしてみてくださいと
褒めてほしいとやっちゃうと欲なんですね
そこで自分が丁寧に掃除機かけたところで
この部屋の人が来たら
ああ すごい綺麗に掃除機しているんですね
すごいですねと褒めてもらいたがっちゃうと
そこにすごい苦しみがあるんです
なぜかというと この人は罪を犯しているんだから
欲でやってるんだから
同じことをやっぱり部屋をしっかりと綺麗にしてあげますと
ここに住む人はもう気持ちいい気持ちで住んでほしいと
それで終わるならば それは不貪の行為で
結果として自分がすごく気持ちがいい
不貪というのはそういう施しの心
その中でもいろいろあります
そういう微かなことをしてあげることやら
自分持っているものをあげることやら
自分の体力労働をあげることやら
あるいは自分の体の一部をあげることやら
命でもあげることやら
いろいろありますけども
怒りの反対は不痴ですか
怒りがないと怒りがない場合は
その代わりに生まれるのはやっぱり慈しみの心なんですね
優しい慈しみに明るい心
で 不痴というのは智慧が無痴ではない心ですね
その時いつでもあったら頭はしっかりして
目がいつでも咲いた状態で
物事はちゃんとありのまま
ハイレスで見ていてということで
それ３つもあってほしい
でもいいことをすると
差が智慧があるかないかなんですね
ということは いいことをすると不貪不瞋は大体あるんです
むさぼりがないというと明るいということで明るいんだったら怒りも入らないんですね
ですから 善行為には必ずしも不貪不瞋は入っています
不痴は入る場合もあって
入らない場合もあります
3つも入ったらすごい良い心なんです
そういうものすごい強い心で良い行為をしたら
必ず良い結果が生まれてくる
大体の人間の善行為はほとんど 2つだけ
原因は 不貪不瞋だけ 不痴はほとんど入らない
ただ楽しいだからいいことをするんだとそれだけ
それについて智慧が働かない
智慧も働くと もうかなりいい行為なんです
そこで仏教の人々に気をつけてほしいなのは
いいことは仏教であろうがなかろうがやってますけど
仏教の人々にはそれはそのように必ずしも智慧も入るように同じことができるんです
掃除 洗濯であろうが何であろうが
智慧も使ってその行動をする
その中から何か智慧を得る
無常を理解する ドゥッカを理解する
無我を理解する 実体ないということ
物事の生滅変化を理解する
あるいは執着やら執着から苦しみが生まれるとかね
執着ないところで心は清らかで軽いとかね
そういういろいろお釈迦様おっしゃる真理を毎日常の生活の中からいつでも発見してみる
料理を作りながら ご飯を食べながら
掃除洗濯しながら お風呂に入りながら
お風呂 お風呂に入ったところで自分でよく分かりますが
自分の体はどんどん消えていくんだと
体の古い細胞やら全部もう取ってしまいますからね
それで疲れた人はもうお風呂に入って上がっちゃったらまた元気になってきて
それで体が変わったんだ
そういう常に自分の体に起こる変化やら
そういうものを理解しながら行動できる
いつでも知恵を使う それは仏教の知識がある人にはできる
特別にできることで 他の宗教の方々も宗教はない方々もいいことはしますよ
大体稀にたまに たまになんですけど
それでもまあする時はしますけど
やっぱりなかなか智慧が働く場がないんです
いいことを聖書で言ってるんだけど
ことをしていますよと言ったのは言うと言われるんだからやってるんだけど
本当はやりたくないという理屈はそこにあるんです
例えば隣人愛っていうのは
あれは聖書で言ってるんだからやってるんであって
あの民族は隣人愛じゃなくても
できればみんな殺したいほどの怒りの性質を持ってる国民民族なんですね
そこでの嫌なんですけど
神に恐れて隣人を愛するということはすると
ということもありますからね
結局僕らから見れば なんとなくなんか悲しく感じちゃうんですね
かわいそうに感じちゃうんです
感じちゃうんですね やっぱり教えがちゃんときちんとしたものでないんだから
結構そこに苦しみが生まれてくる
まあそういうことで このだから神様のためにやってるんだとかね
これやらなかったら天国に生まれ変われませんよとかね
ということになっちゃうと
やっぱり本能はやりたくない
しょうがないんだからやってるんだよということになっちゃうんですね
いいこと そうすると知恵が働かない
仏教っていうのはそうじゃなくて
悪いことをすると暗い心で気持ち悪いでしょうと
いいことをすると明るい心で気持ちいいでしょうと
だから今すぐ結果が出てくるんだから
いいことをしたら そういう人生だったら
もし未来があるならば
さらに巨大な結果が出るでしょうと
だから未来はいつでも推定にしておくんですね
確実に天国に行けるんだからとかね
証拠もないのにそれは言わないんです
未来があるならば あなたは悪いことに行けるはずがないでしょうということで
人間の理屈の範囲の中で考え方を置いておくんです
ということですね 大体そこら辺でこの項目は終わりますけど
で いいことをする場合は 8種類の心がありますと
我々の勝負は知恵がある心を作ることなんですね
例えば楽しい心 楽しくない普通の心っていうのは
そんなに気にしなくてもいいんです
やることは何でもものすごい楽しくやらなくちゃいけないと
それは無理なんです 楽しくはないんだけど
別に苦しくもない状態でやればいいんです
いわゆる冷静な気持ちでやること自体をすごく楽しいんだったら
それもまたいいし 例えば家のすごい重い荷物をあっちこっち片付けなくちゃいけないんだと
で あるいは引っ越しの荷物を全部まとめなくちゃいけない
それはもう労働はかかるわ
手が痛くなるわ 腰が痛くなるわ
は明るくニコニコできるわけないんですね
疲れたとかね ありますから
重いものを運んだりする時とかね
でもその時はまあ喜ぐではなくて謝罪かも知れません
でもそれは別に問題ない
それはやってる仕事次第だから
あるいは自分があまり上手じゃない仕事を頼まれたと
そうするとワクワクしてなんかできないんですね
やっぱり気をつけなくちゃいけない
真剣にやらなくちゃいけないということが出てくるんだから
ニコニコしてできることできないかもしれない
それでも善行としてはできるんですね
ですから 我々いいことをすると心が危うか者かということも
そんなに気にする必要はない
動か動か無業かという
いえ 無業か動か動かということも気にする必要ない
ここだけなんですね コントロールできるのは知恵があるかないか
知恵がなければそこに知恵が生まれるようにすることはできるのです
質問していいですか？はい
今 今話した感じで 布団と布団と布陣とふちっていう話が出てきましたよね
それでふちっていうのは
その穴がある場合がふちが入ってるって考えればいいですか
ニャー音が  今の話の中で布団
アドーサとアドーバはある
ずっとあるって言いました
それでアモーハがある場合とない場合があるって
今おっしゃってました
それでアモーハが入ってるのはニャーが入ってる方だって考える
そうそうそうそう そうですね
アモーハが入るとニャーニャーですね
で この 8つの心っていうのは
この欲界 欲界っていうのは普通の人間と神々と地獄と全部まとめて仏教の欲界と言うんですね
どうせ輪廻転生するのはほとんど欲界の中なんですね
もし人が特別に修行して
心の次元をものすごく飛び出したならば
色界無色界が出てくる
それは禅定の世界で でも生命は瞑想する人っていうのはもうすごいいないんだから
人間の中でもほんの何人かしかいない
その中でも禅定は経験できる人っていうのはもう見つからないほど
もういないんですね ですからということは
もう生命はほとんどもう欲界の中でぐるぐるぐるぐるぐるぐる回ってるんです
地獄に行くは また餓鬼道に行くは
まあアスラに行くは 人間に戻るは
畜生動物になるは 天国に行くは
また戻ってくるは まあそこら辺なんですね
ですから 普通の心のレベルなんですね
もうまた残ってますけど
七つ 善の心はね 七つじゃなくて
いっぱいいたと 九つ で
ありますけど それは瞑想の世界
ですから欲界ではないんです
そこら辺にもうちょっと後に入りましょう
これから欲界の心は全部まとめて説明します
じゃあもうちょっと前に戻ります
この二十六ページの二番目に書いているところ
アヘートゥカチッタ アヘートゥカチッタ
それは日本訳は無因心なんですね
で 無因心という言葉から見ると
なんか因がないということはおかしいでしょうに
心に すべてのものは因縁によって生まれるんだからね
因がないんだったら  そういうのは因がないという意味じゃなくて
このアビダンマでは因という言葉
ヘートという言葉が もう本当は言語学的にはちょっとおかしいんだけど
特別な意味で使っているんです
ヘート このヘートは奥経では因という意味で
アビダンマでは特別な意味で
パーリ語から見れば ヘートというのは原因であって
だからどんなもうこれだけという決まってないんです
どんな原因でも原因であってヘートなんです
それはお経では アビダンマではヘートっていうのは
このローバドーサモーハなんですね
ローバドーサモーハと
こちらの反対でアローバアドーサアモーハ
で ローバドーサモーハ
貪瞋痴 アローバアドーサアモーハ
不貪不瞋不痴 その その六つにヘートというんです
なんでヘートと言うんですかというと
この六つによって善か不善か判断するんです
やはり善悪判断はこの 6つでやっているんです
ちょっと日本語で書きますかね
クサラかアクサラか で
行動は善か不善か こういうトンジンチとフトンフジンフチという 3つで決めるんですね
ですから この善悪判断の場合は
倫理的な立場で倫理的な判断するための因である
ですから ヘトというその意味で使っているんです
そこでアビダンマではアヘトと言えばどういう意味ですか？無因といえば善でもない
不善でもないという意味なんです
善でもない 不善でもないという意味で無因と言うんです
で アヘトですか アヘトという言葉は出ているわけです
アヘトっていうのは無因だから
この 無因というのはこの善でもない
不善でもないという判断はしないという
判断はなしと それはどういうことかというと
人間の心は全部善不善だけですかと
善でもない 不善でもない
いわゆる善悪判断はない
ただ心は心が流れている
そういう時もあります
その心は無 無因 真ですね
18種類があるんです
この 18種類をいくらか説明してから
紹介してから 今は気づいたことなんですけど
この仏教用語ではある特別となると
いつでもこの悪いことはしっかり言うんです
いいことについて否定形使っちゃうんです
例えば老婆と言えばむさぼりであって
じゃあそちらの反対のいいことは老婆でないと言うんですね
私はたまに施しとかなんとか言うんだけど
仏教では使ってないんですね
あれ何でしょうかね そのやり方は
それはその中にもすごいまたあるわけがあるんです
いわゆる悪いことというのはそんなに力があるわけじゃないんです
また これが悪いということも
いわゆるしっかり決められる
老婆ということはしっかり定義できるんです
自分で自分の方向に自分で取りたく
掴みたく 執着したくなるということで
ですから それを反対の方だったら
やっぱり逆に言えば施しという捨てるということなんですけど
そうするとこのこの場合は老婆でない心といえば
このいくらでも成長可能なんですね
いくらでも限りなく成長可能なんです
だから不善の方は限りなく成長可能なんですね
いわゆる我々には まあいいことをすると
やっぱりアローバとアドーサでいいことしている
ちょっと仏教的な知識も入っちゃうと
アローバとアドーサとアモーハでいいことできる
じゃあその人はさらにいいことをする
修行する その時のアローバアドーサアモーハはものすごいレベル高いなんですね
やがて悟るんだと 悟ったという心もアローバアドーサアモーハの心というんです
ですから もし何心にもし老婆ドーサアモーハが完全になくなったならば
消えたならば それは涅槃の心ですよ
ですから そちらにはほんの微かなどうでもいいいいことから解脱
涅槃までいうのも成長過程を考えていて
否定形使ってるんです
だから怒り 怒りは分かります
相手を倒すことだから
怒りない 不瞋と言えば
いくらの方向でも成長できるんです
ただ怒ってないよという風なぐらいでもできるし
人々に対してもっとプラスアルファでポジティブ的にいろんな行動をすることもできるし
もう救国的に人々の心を解脱するように導いてあげることでもできるし
そちらにはもうレベルがたくさんある
罪の場合はそんなないんです
結果から見ても 地獄はどれぐらいがもう決まってるんです
地獄というのは 4つしかないんですね
その中でまたいろいろきめ細かく分析ありますけどね
で それから餓鬼道というものがありまして
世界みたいなもんだからいろんな次元がありますけど
まあ一応レベルは 4つしかないんですね
いくら悪いことしてもそこら辺にしか行く場所ないんですね
まあ我々人間の社会を見ても
人は一人殺しちゃったらどうするんですか？裁判で決めちゃって
まあ刑務所に入れちゃうでしょ
あるいは死刑にする じゃあ二人殺しちゃったら
それでも刑務所に入れるか死刑にするかどうか
そっちなんです じゃあ 5人ぐらい殺しちゃったら
それまた同じ場所 それで刑務所の種類はたくさんあるわけじゃないんです
一人殺した人はこれぐらいの
二人殺したらこれとかね
一人殺したならば一回死刑だと
そういうことはできませんでしょ
ですから まあ悪の法っていうのはね
そんなにもスケールが大きくないんです
次元が少ないんです それなのに人間がこの悪循環から抜けられないことのこの不思議なんですね
悪しか行わない 堕落する方向しかもう知らない
何一つ それはあまりにも地獄の次元にいすぎてね
もう居心地が良くて 上の方向へはなかなかもうちょっと心配なんですね
それはあるんです いいことをするとすぐなんか心配するんですね
それで本当にいいんですか？大丈夫ですか？と
瞑想はよく皆さんは聞くでしょ
こういう風に ただ聞こえている音とかね
そういうふうに確認して本当にいいですか？とかね
大丈夫ですかね それでとかね
だから僕らから見れば
ずっとそういうことではちょっと心配してるということ
いいことには慣れてない
人が何か言うと それを考えて怒ったり
混乱したり 精神的に悩んだり
その人のことを恨んだりして地獄に行くのはもう決まってる
慣れてる慣れてる もうもう無数
回数ね まあ輪廻も過去知らない輪廻でやってきたことだから
もう慣れてるものです
人が悪口言ってると まあ音ですと
というのはできないんですね
あれで本当に大丈夫ですかと偉そうな顔をして聞くんですけど
すごいなんかやっぱり人の言うことをちゃんと聞くべきだよと私は思いますよと
それについてそれなりに考えて考えなくちゃいけないんだと思います
すごいなんか知識的な仮面を被ってるんだけどね
僕に正しいこと 正直に答えならばね
あんたあまりにも地獄に行っていてね
なかなか もう慣れてないだけですよと
居心地が悪いだけですよ
地獄の方が良くて スリランカであります
だったんです 田舎でね
いつも悪いことばっかしやってる人がいて
で 何でしたっけ みんなで私は死んじゃったらやっぱり地獄に行きたいなとかね
何ですか？って言ったら
やっぱりこの火がないんだから
天国に行ったらタバコなんか吸えない
天国でタバコ 1本吸えないんだから地獄の方がいいやと
それはその人の まあそういう面白い話ですけど
やっぱりそこに何か真実があるんです
やっぱり悪いことをしている人にとっては
それはやっぱり居心地がいいんです
あまりにも刑務所に居すぎと居すぎると
もう何かまた犯罪を起こして帰っちゃうんですね
生きていられなくてね
普通の社会で そういうことがあります
そういうことでみんな悪いことしかやりませんだけど
僕 本当の存在の次元から見れば
洗脳世界 明るい世界の方がすっごいたくさんあるんです
全部もう空き家で誰でもいない
そこであの天国はただこのちょっとしたこの我々知っている六天にしても
向こうではね 天国というのは喜びの次元だから
いっぱい生命がいた方が幸福なんです
人間の世界と違って 人口が増えれば増えるほど天国の状態も良くなるんです
天国では明るいこの喜びの波動で生きているんですね
楽しめなくちゃいけないんです
向こうでは ですから もう一人だけで楽しめないでしょう
楽しめなかったら栄養がなくなっちゃいますから
寿命は短くなって早く死んじゃうんですね
せっかくいいことをして天国に行ったっても
ですから この天国の方はたくさん生命はそこに生まれてほしい
逆に地獄の次元では 生命は増えれば増えるほど苦しみも増えちゃう
お互いに憎しみ合ったり戦ったりという精神エネルギーで生きているんですね
いじめ合ったり 苦しめたりとかね
そうすると人が増えるほど苦しみが増えちゃう
天国では逆に人が増えるほど幸福が増えちゃう
人は簡単に地獄の方に行ってしまっちゃいますけどね
そういうことで この一般仏教ではね
一般の普通の一般の人々の仏教を喋る場合は
何かいいことをする場合は一人でやるなと
一般的に自分の国のことしか僕はわかりませんだけど
よく言うんです よくいいことをしたならば
それをしたければ一人でやるなと
みんなを参加させろと
で どういうふうにします？例えば
この向こうでは 仏像の前で
仏塔の前で ブッダ像の前でお花を差し上げて礼をする
それは一つの布施の行為なんですね
釈迦さんに自分の気持ちを表すために花を持ってあげると
そこで日本みたいに綺麗な花はないんだけどね
あっちこっちから取った花なんですけど
それでも気持ちは気持ちですからね
で もし花が 2つぐらい3つぐらい手で持って差し上げるとすると
そこに誰かがいたならば
あなたに 1つとか すぐくれるんです
例えば ちょっと散歩に行ったところで
仏塔が見てちゃんと礼をすると
そういうことを向こうはみんなよくやりますから
その人の手には花がない
そちらちゃんと準備してきた人がいたと
何のことなく はいはい
どうぞどうぞ あなたにも
なんか決まってるような感じで
これは私が持ってきた花だから
あなたは自分で持ってこいという
それはもうそういう日本的な考え方はないんです
あなたはあなたの花を持ってこいと
すごい暗い狭いそういう考え方
だから花をつかむ時でも
これはもう自分で自分だけでお供えするっていうことは全く考えていない
初めから 例えば明かり
照明ですか 油ですか 油を持っていって
高いんだから おばあちゃんたちほんのちょっとしか持っていけないんですね
そこであれを 1つ2つに入れたら終わっちゃいます
それでも誰か誰がそばにいれば
じゃああなたもご一緒にとか
もう2人に分けられませんから
大体手でも2人で手でも合わせて
はいはいとそこでやっちゃう
それで自分のいい行為をもう一人に分けてあげる
一緒にやる その人は誰であろうか
もう何も考えていない
そのお金はありがとうございますとも言わない
それはもう全く関係ない話
すごい欲の世界でありがとうございますと言わなくちゃいけないんですね
あっちではもうごく普通の当たり前のことをしただけだから
そこにありがたいということはないんです
ありがたいなじゃなくて
ありうる話だから あるべき話だから
ですから ありがとうはないんです
ありがとうというのは
本当にそういう個人的に個人の何かしてあげたら
もうただ一言葉でありがとうと言って
それはもう終わることはしません
それなりにすごくそれを覚えておいて
いろんな形でいろんな方法で感謝を表す
ですから 決まり文句ない
ありがとうとかThank youとかね
もうすぐ口癖でThank youなんか言っちゃったら嫌われちゃう
僕はもう遊びに子供たちいろいろ指導させますからね
なんかちょっとまあ僕のところで英語を勉強してきたんだから
僕もすぐもうThank youとかなんとか言っちゃってます
かなりやられちゃったんです
子供たちに